this is Navy SEAL Tom Shea
um I believe you went through SEAL
training the most times out of any Navy
SEAL because is that right
uh thanks man thanks for putting me down
right off the bat the the dubious honor
of uh being the dummy log that stayed
long enough uh yeah I went through I
went into hell week five times
they don't let people do it anymore
because theoretically it damages them
therefore this is a damage good in front
of you yeah so before before we get yeah
before we go into it too much because I
love this is one of my favorite stories
so everybody listening you know I've
known Tom for a few years now you are
not only we're not only a seal for 23
years you are a best-selling author and
this is one of your books we just moved
to Florida so I haven't unpacked the
other one but unbreakable this is the
one that uh your first best seller
fantastic book
honestly stop everything and read it yep
we'll leave the link to all of Tom's
socials in the description yeah we'll
make sure and the book and everything so
it I mean it's fantastic you're a
best-selling author you were you know
you you have been awarded a silver star
a bronze star with Valor multiple combat
Awards right
um You Are I mean really I I don't mean
to you know I hope I'm not embarrassing
you I I just really want to say you are
you are the head of uh or the officer in
charge of sales sniper school at one
point you have trained some of the most
famous seals in in the world you're the
seal behind the seal as I like to think
of you and uh you know having you here
is is a big deal for uh for our first
podcast so I just want the people that
are listening to know that
Tom is the [ __ ] and he's the real deal
and you're like a real badass then
everybody needs to know who you are
because what you bring to the table you
have changed my life you've changed how
I operate my day-to-day with your
intelligence and your approach to living
and
I know you've affected Sunny what time
we were down at your house and he still
talks about what a great conversation he
had so let's let's let's have another
one for sure okay
was that did I get it all right which
one do you want me to ask answer which
one of the five do you want me I we want
to hear your seal your um your training
story first five times well uh yeah
yeah so uh Elena and I have been friends
gosh since
14 or 15.
where you facilitate uh somewhere in
there uh you facilitated Stacy and I
coming out and talking to the
the Boston House of Commons if you want
to call it that and uh uh got to meet uh
some some Teamsters which was very
exciting for us and to got to kind of
tell our story when the book launched
uh if you don't mind me starting with
Unbreakable uh in 2009 uh toward the end
of my 23 year career I was a platoon
Chief and I took a seal platoon over to
Afghanistan
and uh to go to war and that the the
proposition if you will of going to war
on a family man
with three kids and leaving a wife
behind kind of prompted Stacy my wife to
ask me to
give the kids access to me
through writing during that deployment
so the from April to October I was in
Afghanistan going to war
and I wrote letters home to the kids
that became the book Unbreakable
and they were lessons in case I died
that Autumn and Garrett and chance and
even Stacy would be able to
try to apply these lessons in their life
without a father and so for some reason
a knuckle dragger like me could write a
book about life that would hit people
really well
so the book has 13 lessons in it and
they were written from the vantage point
of a warrior in combat trying to fight
his way home to his family
and uh
that's how Elena and I met is she helped
us get on some radio stations and
and then became partners with us about
two years ago to kind of get us out of
our own way and which led to this
conversation so
that's kind of the book in a nutshell
and uh the the process of writing the
book is the same process that I learned
in Seal training is never give up no
matter how bad things are don't give up
and writing to me was worse than combat
because I
didn't think I was a writer
and I didn't think anybody would read
anything and I had no idea that anybody
would so if there's a lot of foul
language in it and a lot of uh personal
authentic moments that I was sharing
with Stacy and the kids that
uh have profoundly moved
tens of thousands of people as they read
it that's what makes it such a good read
though because it's really like you just
speak in your mind as a as a person you
know just very it's so personal the book
yeah I I wish it wasn't but now I think
as an old man I'm like I'm glad it was
personal so there's nothing hidden in it
whatsoever
uh so and you'd asked you know early on
and before we went live uh
what are some profound moments that I
could pass on to people
uh I tried to get through SEAL training
four times in a row and I learned
something that every human should be
able to learn because I think it's a
learnable skill and the learnable skill
that I acquired was starting over
anybody can start over no matter how bad
things are
so I went to every seal every seal has a
class number so the class number I
started out with was class 195.
which I think is April of
92 I think 92 is when that happened or
93
and
I was a good athlete really takes quite
an athlete to get into still training it
takes uh either somebody that's crazy or
nutty to make it through
so we classed up that class with 150
kids and hell week then was week five
and I made it into hell week and by the
time we were in hell week we'd already
whittled down to 80.
and uh I got a concussion
in front of the hotel Dell and woke up
in the hospital
and I was offered what every kid has
offered a chance to come back
but in reality it didn't feel like a
chance so a guy named Mike Mayer who's
the chief of the first phase at the time
came to the hospital and he said all
right
here's the deal
you're now in the hospital
and we pulled you out of hell week we
want you to sign the paperwork that you
quit
and I'm like no I'm not going to sign it
and he goes the fact that you got
knocked out is also quitting so just
forego all this crap and sign the
paperwork because
we have found out that people who get
injured are quitters as well
I'm like wow so I'm not going to sign it
and he goes okay if you're not going to
sign it
come back to the first phase when they
kick you out of the hospital and you get
a two-week break
and then you have to start over from
square one from day one from the
beginning how did you get this
concussion too by the way like how
severe was it
I mean uh I don't know the grade of it
but I was I woke up in the hospital so
it was a high grade concussion
and I probably have so much scar tissue
in my brain that uh uh
it probably probably
in today's like athleticism on the
football field probably wouldn't been
able to play football again because
anytime you get knocked out for a period
of time they won't let you play
so that two-week period of time is
really uh the first experience I had
that uh
can I start over like everybody
every young kid man or woman
uh until they're around 30 to 35 passes
through that you have failed at
something whether you quit whether you
were kicked out whatever you failed
and I had to for two weeks try to figure
out what was inside of me that was
badass enough to get me to go back to
training
and I found out that there's not a lot
of support in the world
parents weren't supportive I had a
girlfriend at the time she goes man
don't go back you're going to get hurt
and I had a guy well I now call a mentor
that had been a seal in World War II
said hey
start over and I'm like hey Pat
starting over means I got to go back to
the beginning he goes good start over
because if you quit it'll stick with you
until you die if you walk away having
quit
it'll stick with you forever
so after the two-week break I went back
to the training and said I'm here
they didn't care
they beat me just like I was a new a new
kid and you still can't I learned
what was that I said you're still
concussed at this point I mean only two
weeks
uh no I got back from leave and then I
had another three and a half weeks
before the official training started but
you're still working out
and what I found out is great people
don't care about your issues
if they don't care if you have a
concussion quit if you're not going to
be here quit if you're injured quit or
stay
and I
love the seal community and the fact
that they're not emotionally involved
with your injuries and your drama
either you're going to stay or you're
going to leave and they don't care
either way
so I started up again class 196
and it was very different I thought it
was going to be the same but the
instructor staff did not like the
leadership of that class and we really
paid
physically for the leadership Dynamic of
the class leadership
and so I made it to hell week again a
little bit further in hell week and we
are pulling these thousand pound boats
over a 12 foot obstacle and I was on the
one side and everybody else was on the
other
and I was pulling and they pushed right
at the last the most inopportune time
and separate and dislocated my right
shoulder
and the staff saw it happen
and they said you can ring the bell or
you can stay
so my shoulder's now out of socket and I
decided to stay
so for 20 hours I had
I had I couldn't move my hand and my
hand had swollen up to probably two and
a half times size and it was turning
purple
and finally a doctor said you got to get
your hand above your head
if you can't get it above your head
we're pulling you out
and I couldn't do it so they pulled me
out put take took me to medical and gave
some some drugs so that my muscles were
would relax and then they popped it back
in which was a whole new level of
a lot of foul language came out of my
mouth agony
oh terrible and they're like all right
here's the deal
you get two weeks or you get to miss a
class
if you want to stay
and you get to miss a class to recover
your shoulder
but on day one you have to pass the test
so I had six weeks to ruminate on the
woe is me should this be me and nobody's
supporting me and Pat was the only one
that said good
now you know what the battle is you got
to get back in shape you got to stay in
shape and you got to do it from a point
of inferiority
so I did recover my shoulder I came back
for the class 198 which is now winter
winter in San Diego
you're not friendly
story it's wild that's like I don't
really I don't like the ocean anymore I
never did as a seal it's just work and
it's freezing cold
so I started class 198 and I had
recovered my shoulder and I think my
attitude was the best it had ever been
and it rained and stormed for four
straight weeks we couldn't even get the
boats through the surf zone because the
break in San Diego in the wintertime is
right on the shore and we were wet and
cold and Sandy for four weeks and I had
the undertones of pneumonia going into
hell week
and on Wednesday of hell week uh
I passed out
from pneumonia
and
they took me to hospital and my mayor
the same Chief came to the hospital and
said
I I know you're not going to quit
there's just a a bet if you're going to
quit or stay
and I said I'm not going to quit but my
or chief I know I can't pass the
entrance test
and he goes we're not even interested in
you passing the interest interest test
we want to see if somebody will come
back for the fourth time
nobody's ever come back for a fourth
time
no
wow not at all and I wish I hadn't it
was brutal so
that was on a Thursday morning that I
kind of got out of the hospital
the problem was the next class started
on Monday
there wasn't a two-week break
and I'm like oh my God so I went into
hell week
keep going he's just being stressed okay
go ahead I went into hell week with uh
pneumonia four lobes of my lungs or four
of the lung things
had about 20 percent infiltration with
fluid when I started
and I was struggling the whole time made
it to hell week at the fifth week and I
couldn't I couldn't do more than 10
push-ups and they didn't care
like see if you can make it through hell
week let's see what you got in you
and uh
I will uh two hours before the cut off
where if you make it to Wednesday night
and there and you have an injury they
usually roll you forward
so at 10 o'clock at night
uh walking over to the chow hall
a doctor was standing next to me and he
said all right cough in my hand so I
cough blood in his in his hand he goes
how you feel and I couldn't talk
and he goes your lips are purple and I'm
like I understand my lips are purple can
we just make it to Chow
and uh I woke up in the hospital on
Friday
and uh they had kicked me out of
training they had medically rolled me
out of training
and uh
so I hadn't quit
but I'm now no longer in still training
I'm working at a hospital or at the
hospital in San Diego because I was a
corpsman as a as a rate or a trade
and I was supposed to stay out for two
years
to give value to the regular Navy
and every day for two years I got the
coaching from Pat again he goes all
right here's the deal either you're
going to go back or you're going to be
in the Navy and I'm like bro I ain't
going to be in the Navy I'm not
interested in the Navy
he was all right every day you need to
go to the Admiral's office and request
to go back to Seal training
so I was an E5 at the time started going
to the Admiral's office every day that I
was at work for nine months and at month
four he came out and ordered me not to
come back and I went back the next day
and I had what they call Admiral's Mast
where he took one of my ranks from me
and I went back on Monday after being
demoted and stayed in this office every
Lunch Period of time
and at the nine month Mark he walked out
he must have had
something positive happened to him on
that weekend and uh he came out and
signed the chit he goes either you're
the dumbest guy in the world or maybe
you have a chance
so I went back to class 207 and made it
through we started out with 111
men and we graduated 11.
11. that's crazy
that whole time where you were so you
were working full-time and you must have
been pretty much training full-time
right
uh I was in the best shape of my entire
life before then or after
because I knew what was expected
physically
to get through every day so I trained at
that level for nine straight months
and uh
I came back with a really high score
and but I'd also learned from Pat was uh
you don't have to win Perfection is the
enemy of good
you just need to make it through every
day not injured that's the deal
and I took that to heart
because I was highly competitive in my
first trial
in the second one I need to tow the line
every day whatever it takes to toe the
line and don't get injured even if you
have to get last place to not get
injured don't get injured and that is a
another profound thing that youth
doesn't Discover until they're wise
when when you had pneumonia were you
like hallucinating while doing the steel
oh terrible terrible what kind of what
are you seeing do you remember any of it
good question uh I don't know if I was
seeing visions more than really
believing how bad things were
like I started believing how terrible I
I was and let's get down on yourself and
then you really believe how terrible you
are and when somebody says you know
you're a POS you know you're like oh you
you're right and uh
that that negativity that you have when
you're totally injured
uh was what I call the the belief in the
hallucination effect it's man you really
believe your own
downtime so with SEAL training you said
it's the first four weeks and then hell
week
um what's the first four weeks like is
that more just like what a typical uh
military boot camp would be like
it's still way worse and then hell week
is just the final
look at it this way hell week is a
culmination of the four weeks packed
into one week so whatever you did in
four weeks they give you in one week
so four or five days of no sleep right
like straight
you don't you or well on paper you get
between an hour and a half to three
hours
but you don't know you're supposed to
you're allowed to sleep so the
instructor staff will say all right uh
you know down boat everybody get around
you know under their boat and we'll be
back so you're anticipating that they're
going to beat you so not everybody
sleeps
uh the people that have seen it like I
was if an instructor's not demanding
anything of you lay down and fall asleep
who cares they're going to yell at you
anyway so on paper it's three hours
in reality some students don't get sleep
the lack of sleep isn't the biggest
issue is that on day one of hell week
they make you not capable of doing
anything physically you're already at
the
you're already at 10 percent
Effectiveness and then the rest of the
training just coincides with it there's
a Non-Stop mental physical beatdown
But to answer your question and all the
training is designed to break you down
physically and mentally every day
give you unwinnable and unattainable
tasks on a day-to-day basis to see if
you're going to quit on yourself
so all SEAL training or at least the
buds training is about giving you a
thousand scenarios that are unwinnable
to see if one of those is the scenario
that you're going to quit on
cold
you know times that are so hard that you
can't do it and and then they brow beat
you constantly
to see if I can talk I if I can yell at
you to get you to quit we want to make
sure that you leave
and uh that's and the cold water the
cold water is the differentiating factor
on
on most people
so this is you know
you've you've taught me a lot about
and part of it's part of your training
the the excuses you know that that we
just talk ourselves out of success all
day every day by making excuses and was
this something that you were like
um aware of like in the front of your
mind you know like oh that that's just a
that's just an excuse I gotta kill it
back then or is you know like how did
you get through that how did you kill
those excuses because you probably had a
million Reasons to Quit every minute of
every day through all of this uh the
answer answer that it's more uh at the
maybe the four-letter word wise once you
become wise to things once you've done
something four or five times you realize
there's some
uh subtle things that are more important
than the gross things so uh they don't
tell you
they say there's three ways out of
training
break
fail or quit
you can fail academically
you can break a bone and get kicked out
or you can quit those are the only three
ways out of training come to find out
those are the three ways out of life
whether it's in a marriage or a business
or athletic Endeavor or School you
either fail out of school or you get
sick and can't take a test or you quit
school
relationship same way you can quit a
relationship
uh they you can break yourself down
physically so that you're not available
or you can kind of fail at a
relationship by activity you know what I
mean uh so when you're a student
all you realize is this sucks so bad why
am I here that's the question that
you're asked you're asking yourself all
the time
uh and they just give you so many
scenarios that are make you question
what you're doing
by the time you become wise to it or
when you're an instructor you realize
the only thing preventing anybody from
doing anything wonderful
are there reasons that they have in
their head
so excuses and reasons are the same
thing
uh and a guy named Draper Kaufman who
wrote the hell week curriculum
said at the end of Hell Week the only
thing the boss or leader should say
the difference between you people who
are standing here at the end and the
other people
or that they gave up and you didn't
and I'm like wow what a profound
statement so that's what the skipper
says at the end of every hell week the
only difference between you
and them is that you made a promise and
kept it
you didn't quit
yeah on yourself
come to find out that's a learnable
skill what if you learned
to keep doing things no matter what your
brain your body or your environment is
telling you
so that's the key factor of why seals
are so effective in combat is because
they're committed they're either going
to die or they're going to make it
through it doesn't have to make sense to
anybody but they're either going to die
or make it through
and that level of
brain activity or whatever the
existential
you know question is
you can learn that in every factor of
your life
in business like what you guys are doing
with Tick Tock and YouTube
you could quit
you could quit or you could keep coming
back learn from every single mistake
and if you quit that's where it stops
and if you don't quit like what you guys
are doing
it doesn't I don't understand what the
heck you guys are doing but had you quit
it would have been very understandable
you know you know what I'm saying yeah I
know what you're saying the way I've
started looking at struggle is every
piece of [ __ ] there like every [ __ ]
that I have to deal with throughout my
day it's just raising my tolerance of
stuff that I can deal with so now at 19
years old like constantly putting myself
through struggle and you know constant
stress I realize that I'm so far ahead
of everyone else and
um for my age I
I can deal with a lot more stuff
business-wise
social media wise than anybody else
because I'm constantly putting myself
through that struggle so would you say
after going through some of the hardest
struggle that there was with SEAL
training that it's just made you like
your business life relationships all of
that much easier because you're like
I've been with way worse so I can 100
get out of this
uh that's the definition of resilience
you you qualified resilience resilience
is the repetitive uh
Adventures into things that are not easy
so anybody who has resilience as a
moniker
has failed millions of times they've
struggled millions of times
and uh that's that's where growth comes
from
and
that's what people should be doing
constantly
go go into the zones that want to
annihilate you quite often
and they will and then and then Tuesday
learn from it don't do the same stupid
thing again that's resilience
don't keep making the same mistake which
is what emotions are you keep making the
same mistake and you keep doing it and
you keep doing it but you never change
uh
it I never think that what I'm doing
isn't as important as the combat
I think business is combat it's just how
many times can you struggle
and not that this is less of a struggle
than combat like you know what I'm you
know what I'm saying I don't think this
is less important than what was going on
in combat I think it's equal
can can we make a choice right now that
we can survive that's all combat was
and combat was a series of fallen off
the ledge going man
we can't do that again and then building
yourself back up in the next millisecond
and then building yourself back up in
the next millisecond
hmm
very interesting yeah this is what this
is what we're constantly doing I mean
you know we're we're here now we're
working together
um
it just seems It's a roller coaster
starting this new Venture yeah so we
just have to keep and again I go back to
you I remember my excuses when my head
starts going and I'm paying attention to
my own voice in my head and trying to
kick kick out the garbage you got to
keep going with that though I mean I
feel like I've learned that I learned
that from you a few years ago and I'm
still
beating that you know like it's still
beating that uh back all the time it's
so easy right it's just so easy to turn
around and go you know this is hard this
is stupid why am I doing this I'm
frustrated
I'm tired all the things
yeah well you know from a third party
perspective watching what you and Sonny
are doing
uh go back to as long as it makes sense
to the people in the fight
it'll work
from the outside
when you were sharing with Stacy and I
the nft
I asked myself what the hell is an nft I
don't get it I don't get it I don't get
it somebody got it yeah and I excuse
myself from understanding it you know
what I mean
so that excuse of
well it doesn't make sense I don't have
to engage you guys didn't do that I did
there's a think about the millions of
people out there that say well I don't
understand it therefore I'm not going to
pursue it they missed what you guys
gained
yeah and I still don't understand what
the heck you did
but you did you know you know that
that's the miracle of business is
and y'all y'all figured it out how many
times did you want to give up yeah oh
I'm yeah I mean that's where I learned
the most lessons with the was with my
last company because oh my God just so
many mistakes that I made that I should
have done better but every time we were
in like one of the crappiest situations
I was like all right now my tolerance
level is up to here so if I get out of
this situation then that means that 99
of other BS that I have to deal with is
underneath this and it means that I can
guaranteed get out of it because I
already got out of this thing so if you
look at struggle like you said I mean
I'm talking you know I don't gotta tell
you this but if you look at struggle
like for the audience if you're going
through the hardest thing of your life
if you recognize that you can get
through that then literally everything
else becomes much easier with business
with life
yeah I mean I've had that mentality for
a long time like I I look back over my
life over the ups and downs and like
well it always ends up working out it's
you know just to oversimplify it it
always ends up working out so why am I
gonna flip out over every little thing
there's no sense it's actually the
little things that I end up flipping out
over not the big things which is just a
emotional you know that was the uh
Dylan you know to as you Elena came into
what we were trying to accomplish uh I
had written my second book which was a
better way to articulate struggle and
and uh resilience
of how you make complex things simple
and people who are successful
as you're trying to articulate it sunny
was uh
the struggle is up here I can endure the
struggle longer than anybody else you
can endure the complexity longer and
every time something's complex you try
to find things that are simple that you
can actually execute on
what most people do is keep things too
complex for too long and nothing's
actionable
uh resilience is by definition
finding simplicity
I have to find something I can do
most people hold their breath under
panic
you know you can't function if you hold
your breath so there's a simple solution
breathe okay breathe what at what can we
do right now even though there's five
thousand things going on what's one
thing we can do then I had a a mentor at
the time when I was writing three simple
things was the human can only do three
things at one time it can't do four like
wow where does that number come from
he said most most great businessmen have
three direct reports
those direct reports have three direct
reports by the time a businessman who's
successful or woman has more than three
direct reports their business is in
turmoil
if the leader
spends more than a third of his his or
her time with another human being
it gets complicated like wow that's a
leadership simplicity
learn by struggle struggle struggle
uh and then
I found those three simple things are
everywhere
if it gets complex find three things
that you can do
and you can do them every day don't if
you never get to the fourth one because
there's a million important things
which three are you going to articulate
it doesn't matter do three there's not a
priority just do three
and that's 99 more than everybody else
because they're doing
because everybody else is trying to do a
thousand things and then nothing I gotta
make a thousand phone call yeah I know
there's nothing done with like my to-do
list because I always have stuff to do
because I'm always starting new
businesses or I can make content or do
something so with my I have my massive
to-do list with stuff that just needs to
get done and then I have my today to-do
list and I used to pile on way too much
stuff and I noticed when I would do that
almost none of it would get done but
then when I put like
six to eight things that I know that I
can get done I can do this in one hour
this one hour and it's organized a lot
nicer then I'm way more productive so
that's 100 that's kind of the same
um ideology yeah the number uh is not
like a steadfast one but by the time you
get three things done you'll probably
have opportunity to get the fourth fifth
sixth seventh eighth
but if you try to do 10
you're screwed right off the bat hmm
100 of the time and it's a good
analytical approach to success is you're
going to have a massive list everything
on there is a priority
like the the the the word priorities
doesn't exist everything is a priority
which one am I going to pick
it doesn't matter pick one
and execute it until it's done being
executed not everything's going to
mature on day one but okay I've moved
that three inches down the field I can
probably take my thumb off the pulse of
it now move this one until okay it's
somewhat right
move the next one you may actually get
to 10 that day but the idea is to keep
it simple and move three
yeah if you move three get to more
that's yeah that really is great advice
because I remember even at the start of
my whole entrepreneurial journey and I
was just starting to journal which is by
far one of the best life changes that
I've ever made is recording your day and
realizing like taking accountability so
if you've wasted a whole day you write
that down and then the next day you're
like when I write down my day I don't
want to have to write down that I was a
jackass all day I want to write
something productive
so
when I started journaling and writing up
my next day I would make very simple
tasks I'd be like I'll watch two YouTube
videos about real estate or I'll watch
three videos in this program that I just
bought very simple stuff and then simply
making that first step a year that was
only a year and a half ago and now I'm
able to film my whole day up with new
stuff and I would do I'm doing a hundred
times more than I did initially but a
lot of these people don't just take push
that snowball down the hill first and
then nothing ever ends up getting done
nothing ever becomes articulate or
identifiable
the worst thing you can do is do
anything at half value
it's literally a condition that
everybody should stop
and somehow it's being taught like do a
bunch of things
don't do one thing everybody's
successful
does one thing exceptionally well
like look at Warren Buffett he does one
thing exceptionally well
if he did a bunch of things at half
value you wouldn't even know his name
yeah
you know what I mean he may have a
thousand things under him but he he's he
does one thing exceptionally well and he
knows this is my forte and he executes
that every day and it may be efficient
maybe he gets it done in two hours now I
have a free day
to go after the things that I can
actually move down the field
uh and that is always the case all pro
athletes do one thing really well
not to mention and uh I I'd interviewed
a guy named Kyle Dake who's now the
four-time world champion in wrestling
and he
practices one thing every single day I
mean oh my God one thing he goes I get
better at it every day
I've done it a billion times in a
billion and one I get a little better
and I'm like what is that it's that
Simplicity and the basics like
ballerinas they take a class at the bar
class and every single day you know the
the top ballet companies in the world
they're taking class together every day
doing the very basic things they did
when they were seven years old well I
have a question for you sonny what is
one basic thing in social media that you
know works
I was just gonna talk about that I was
gonna say I specialize in Tick Tock so
when I'm going on to YouTube or I'm
starting a podcast or something I'm not
going to try to run Facebook ads to
promote it I'll do what I know works
best so I'll make tick tocks and stuff
out of it short form content and post it
on Tick Tock reels and shorts and that's
really the best way to go viral right
now by far
and
it's do you fully understanding one
thing really well does that one thing
being successful have ramifications in
other platforms 100 it's a big reason
that my YouTube's blown up so much and
that's what we're going to help you out
with your YouTube career too yeah so for
you guys seeing that's that's the most
brilliant thing that everybody listening
can understand
is Master One Thing
you may at the end of a life have 80
things that you're the master of but
from the vantage point of a master I'm
only good at one thing
I can I just taught a a weapons thing
this weekend to several my clients
and it's basics
like front sight Focus that's basic
is there any other thing no if you can't
get that let's not even move on to
anything else and slow trigger squeeze
do you remember when you told me follow
through the you're good the top one of
the top woman snipers in the world when
you hung out with her and you said
what's the biggest thing that you
practice and she said she breathes and
picks up the gun isn't that what you
said that's that's what uh well uh
there's a competition called Palma which
is open site 100 800 900 000 yard
distance shooting through an open site
not a scope
uh her basic saying is
breathe
sight
squeeze it's the only thing she
practices breathe
yeah breathe and then sight is the gun
alignment the gun gets into position
uh and then squeeze
and she does it 2 000 times a day that's
all that she does I'm like do you
practice anything else she goes no if
you come for a week that's all we're
going to do
breathe sight squeeze breathe sight
squeeze I'm like oh my God this is
boring she goes that's why I'm number
one I'm the most boring shooter in the
world there's nothing great about it
there's no all this you know accolades
that comes after I breathe sight squeeze
and I practiced with her for a week and
it was transformative getting back to
basics
it was crazy my skills went up
so far
just stick it with the basics so for
people who are listening though and they
get you know so his a lot of Sonny's
audience they want to be social media
entrepreneurs you know marketers or
content creators
like what what are you hearing what do
these people want to do out there and I
guess the what I'm getting at is
it when you start thinking about what
you want to accomplish it gets very big
very fast and you start thinking about
all the things that you got to do in all
the places you know and what to go back
to where you're saying you know pick the
three but it'd even have to it even has
to narrow down you know smaller than
that to really get started right he was
saying that yeah yeah pick one thing and
be really good at it so for these people
like yeah how
how do you do that because it's not easy
it takes practice to think the way you
do Tom
yeah well I was going to ask Sonny uh
what's one thing you do in social media
every day that ends in y
every day
[Music]
you make sure to get a video out every
day there was a video posted every
single day yeah I guess posting a video
every single day I'm trying to think of
like the one basic thing that I go over
every single day
I mean I have to think about it yeah
most people won't be able to articulate
it that have already won like if you
talk to the top people in the world it's
what's one thing you do every day
they're like man I don't know if I can
boil it down to one thing but if You
observe them like if I would ask Elena
what's one thing you do every day asking
Elena what Sunny does she would pick it
up yeah like God I wish he wouldn't be
like a pig and dig his nose into that
every day take a break
uh
but that one thing
what's one thing you just can't put to
you like man I got to do this
I'd say
it's interesting because I I don't know
what he's doing all the time because
because I'm on my phone he's on the
phone because I'm thinking of something
related to tick tock that I do
I don't know I guess what do you do on
the phone
I guess scroll
I guess what I do is I organ like I
don't watch Tick Tock like a typical
consumer so when I watch it I organize
the videos that I watch into categories
so if I notice a video is being edited
particularly well I'll take note of that
and I'll put it into a specific category
that way I can share it with my
community or if people do a good way of
driving people to their Lincoln bio
without the social media companies
picking up on it because a little tip is
a big goal the social media companies
have is to keep you on their platform as
long as possible so if you're constantly
driving people to your Lincoln bio and
off their platform they won't push your
video as hard so you have to come up
with creative ways to get people to go
to your Lincoln bio and find your other
social medias and there's a ton of
different ways you can do that
creatively so I'll take note of that
kind of stuff I'd say really just going
through my notes and
going over what I see is working for
other people is the biggest thing that I
do every day because that's one of the
biggest tips that I have is whenever
you're going into a new Niche or you're
starting a new plan you want to look at
what the top people are already doing
inside of that Niche and just rip what
all of them are doing best and implement
it into your own thing that's what I did
with the nft account when we first
started it it was basically copying the
other top nft account in the whole on
all of Tick Tock but we just did it
better and ultimately got 20 times more
views than him when I went into well so
uh everybody's listening uh
that is a condition called I have to
find something that moves me every day
it's called inspiration
most successful people have to find
something that moves them or inspires
them every day and they'll spend an
enormous amount of time finding that
yeah whether it's in social media
whether it's in human engagement or
whether it's in their own activity
they'll go to work to try to find
somebody at work that goes okay that's
that was awesome
or
not randomly searching social media find
something that okay wow that was moving
that dude did it and then
finding inspiration every day is the
sole purpose of success
if you're not doing that every day don't
do anything else oh 100 I couldn't agree
we found a way to do that but even
though you didn't understand it yeah
well that was more of just the social
media things the first thing that I do
every morning is I read my goals so I
have my annual goals which are more
basic stuff like one of my annual goals
this year was 100 million views on
hashtag Sunny fast and I already hit
that one so I would read that first
thing every day along with my other
stuff and then I also have monthly goals
which are more of steps that I'm taking
to achieve those goals so for this month
I have like start posting on YouTube at
least once a day fully launch my Academy
get my new affiliate program up and
running the new software good to go
because those are steps that take me
closer to achieving my annual goals and
then another thing to add on about how
you were talking about getting really
good at one specific thing once you
master that one thing it makes you way
better at other stuff too so for you
exam people I'm assuming the thing that
you've mastered is speaking right and
motivating people
so now you can do podcasts you can do
public speaking you can make short form
content you could do coaching you can do
a million different things out of this
one skill I've mastered Tick Tock I can
teach people tick tock I can blow up
Tick Tock accounts I can use them for
businesses I can run Tick Tock ads I can
do a million different things from this
one skill that I've learned
you know Chinese must love you Chinese
love me yeah yeah I'm feeding them they
fund you they don't love you enough if
they're not sending money yeah
you'll get paid in Yen or whatever it is
also uh
that's what the pursuit of three simple
things is and as I listened to that I
always try to find the three simple
things people do
and so you articulate them well I'm just
going to feed it back to you inspire
purpose and action Inspire purpose and
action
he spends a lot of time trying to find
something that is inspiring to him
he finds purpose which is goal Driven
Life and then immediately have to act on
something every day
even though it sounds complex if you
look at activity it looks complex okay I
got something that inspired me I have
purpose because I know where I'm going
and I have to take action every single
day that ends and Y for the rest of my
life on those inspirational
purpose-driven things
that's three
it may have taken all day to execute on
those three simple things
and as you look at that and you find
that in other people that's what you're
solving in Tick Tock is getting people
into those three simple things
if they're not inspired by it you'll
find that it's a dark place like you're
trying to give them action and
executable things they're not turned on
by it they're like oh man I don't like
Tick Tock then you'll find it
next the four-letter word next comes out
of your mouth
and as you I would say what I've learned
in coaching is getting those three
simple things on paper very quickly what
inspires you what's your purpose and
what can you act on
and you're giving people action and
purpose
don't forget that they have to be
inspired they have to find something
about what they do is inspiring or they
have to be inspired by Tick Tock if it
doesn't move them
if it's just a transactional thing
they'll burn you out so quick okay sunny
I want to make a million dollars on tick
tock but you're driving the inspiration
it'll it'll diminish you
like what we're doing Atlanta together
eventually it was lacking inspiration
because it wasn't nothing could
materialize yeah shoving trying we
should have no we should have noted the
inspiration was gone very quickly and
moved on to something else you know yeah
my fault I'm a slow I'm a slow learner
though truly I I am stubborn and once I
learn I learn well but I I know that
about myself and I'm I'm one of the
things I work on with myself is learn
faster adapt faster change faster
because you run it out of time not gonna
live forever oh yeah yep I gotta hurry
up but I have found you know in the in
this three months with sunny the first
few months sitting and thinking
you know I had I had to go down this
road for a few months before I figured
out what my inspiration was before I
really figured out what am I doing here
because this was an accident you know he
invited me to come onto his show to do a
react a mom reaction video that was
supposed to be amusing
and it blew up and then he's like you
wanna do another one yeah blew up and so
you know it's it's actually now we've
now we're a team and we're doing this
thing together but it was unexpected so
I didn't have a purpose going in other
than just to support him
that purpose still exists but I needed
to find my own and now I do have that so
sometimes you know it's it it may not be
linear you may have come up with a
purpose yeah you know sometimes you just
gotta run and then figure out for me I
had to run down the road and then figure
it out and now I feel like I've got you
know I've got some clarity on what my
role is 100 I'm trying to accomplish
here
yeah it's fun we're having a good time
it's notable so Stacy Stacy watches your
shenanigans and I she goes hey watch
this and I'm like oh my God she's Elena
looks different
like The Inspirations there and it's it
articulates itself and other people
observing it which is
transactable you have you have
always
believed in me or led me to believe that
you believed in me and uh I really
appreciate that because it's been
awesome it's been a hard business
through covet you know we're looking at
we're doing Live Events and and you know
you got either even in places where you
could hold them the law was allowing
people to gather there were people who
were afraid so it was hard to pull
people together we talked about that a
lot during covert it was exhausting yeah
I asked Elena to do the impossible and
it was impossible it turns out it was
actually impossible yeah or for me come
to find out it was actually not possible
this one but but because I guess we had
a different purpose and there was a
different road we were supposed to take
we're still going to get where we wanted
to go though
and that's what's up 100 this is a lot
more fun yeah you've you've arrived it's
nice to see that for sure well we're
just getting started
so I I think we should wrap it up
because we could talk to you and keep
you here all day and night
um I have a hundred more questions but
we have Stacy coming on your wife is
coming on uh yeah we have her and then
we actually have another podcast book
with you I know like around six weeks
from now where the both of you as a
couple as a couple oh my God stay tuned
for heavy rolls
you guys are so fun together there's so
much I mean there's just so much
personality and you have so much she's
off the rail now I I can't control it
it's uh it's off the rails She's Fresh
put it
yeah she said she's fantastic
so we're gonna have you back and I and I
can't wait and we'll let you know when
this goes up live and we'll you know
awesome we're gonna keep talking
appreciate it yep and just so you guys
know I'll drop all of Tom's socials and
unbreakable in the comments and three
simple things the links to both yeah
yeah both excellent reads like I said I
just haven't unpacked three simple
things yet
getting there yep
we're getting there perfect thank y'all
all right thank you Tom I'll talk to you
later
[Music]
[Music]